How do we evaluate
an intrusion detection system?
We typically use accuracy metrics
to measure the detection algorithm.
We use detection rate or
true positive rate to measure how
well an IDS can detect intrusions.
That is,
given that there is an intrusion,
how likely would the IDS
correctly output an alert?
We can also use force negative rate.
That is how many intrusions did we miss?
Another aspect of detection
accuracy is the false alarm rate.
That is,
given that there's no intrusion,
how likely is the IDS is going
to falsely output an alert?
We can also use true negative rate.
That is, how likely normal activities
are currently classified as normal?
And if you are a sysadmin,
you may want to know about
the Bayesian detection rate of an IDS.
That is, given that the IDS
has already produced an alert.
How likely is it that an intrusion
actually occurs in your network?
We can more formally
summarize these metrics.
Here, we use A to represent alarm or
positive.
I to represent intrusion.
Detection rate or true positive
rate is the probability that
given there's an intrusion, how
likely the IDS will produce an alert.
And false negative rate is
1 minus true positive rate.
False alarm rate is the probability
that, given that there's no intrusion.
Not I, meaning it's normal.
How likely an IDS would
incorrectly output an alert?
And true negative rate is
1 minus false alarm rate.
Bayesian detection rate
is the probability that
given there's an IDS alert,
how likely there's likely an intrusion.
In addition to the detection algorithms,
you can also evaluate IDS in terms
of it's system architecture.
We want the IDS to be scalable.
Meaning that,
it can function at high speed networks.
We also want the IDS to
be resilient to attacks.
Meaning that, it is not easily disabled
by attacks that target the IDS.